okay okay I'm back oh that's my I I
don't know what the heck is in my eye
it hurts it hurts oh oh
you ever had like dry eyes and put in
like oh ah he put in like oh my gosh my
eyes are burning a dying a dike there's
one I don't care that I can't
okay well beautifies they put an ad up
someone yeah I just starts like burning
and crying and it's hard anyways attempt
away hopefully apply this guy now I know
it's stacked with a lot me now so it
doesn't matter
you love unconditionally okay here's
what a run
Shelley he says the man with the short
sleeves I just chat like what happened
now about eight hours you know there's
so we're going to be in here
all right I hate those things
I really hate those things like more
than anything else you know I thought
now it's going on here what is all this
like there's no just like if I only
stopping at like abandoned buildings
look at this I just literally broken
this one's out and just murder it up
that's somewhere quick an idea I can't
hello sorry hey Dad today
Wow oh oh oh my god ow
Oh first I died in this game wedding
right and now just kidding that'd be
crazy mm-hmm I hate this stupid things
okay can I activate this yet again
mm-hmm-hmm Pam well he died very quickly
alright Advan kill a cow okay yeah well
I got tunnel that's disgusting it's like
a stupid thing Oh gross Khaled Khaled
and fresh nothing any air um whoa
actually shot the thing back I guess you
can reflect it and I got water I'm just
a proud does hey now look at me look at
my li pay day okay my help is horrible
I borrowed your shovels I dig a well
hello sir
I got your spoon I guess I'll heal you
know line up my ears itch it's an eye
why is that they're running button mm
okay
I'll play a lot of game that was going
too deep when I get out all right let me
beat the heck I just love going in
people's houses and just beat in the
heck out of them okay here's the plan I
wait for her to leave and I shoot him
okay I got one
come on out of the way Dorothy come on
come to Papa the other way
come on come on come on for daddy
there's this so crazy ain't been movin
why ain't they Melvin yeah
come on Cyrus hey guys here most tonight
she's I guess I have no choice just a
Kappa
oh my god I can't let you out of that
okay let's give God and they fed and a
gas line okay I just need fed oh god oh
god
Jesus it's so far away
no crappers Oh crappers
okay food I guess things right here
oh my god I was going to die
I'm missing something is there key
somewhere I can exit out okay it's
better there's no what reasons me to go
there they're going to left
it's just a robber in there I think okay
I need some health man dude got those
gay man I've seen I've seen better days
why'd you go in like that okay I'm gonna
go left in the car see there's so much
walk in this game and I just want to
find some chicken nuggets
so here disgusting just disgusting just
really gross
can't be playing until I get I get that
food that's right there if it's in here
you know right now
okay got some items hope they can craft
some food right below basically
everything I'm not gonna lie
not doing too hot this game not still
hot just name two things I'm checking I
guess you know oh my god they perished
oh okay now reason tag on Mac now recent
gotten there I'm just going to go in
here and light them up
hmm business in here or in here get
ripped connected okay Jesus
oh my god I'm so lucky there's a food
okay good that out of here let's blow
this joint
Wow
I only how I can't get helped up between
missions you know I'm just going to call
this loss let's get out of here look at
me red eyed and just just plain crazy
and I just like guys I've seen some
things that's all I'm saying
times I got yeah bad is that's going
yeah bet it is okay I need to crap oh my
god
ha ha man skin turkey skin turkey I have
seen this tentacle thing female ones
that run and laying your face migrate it
crashed and one of these like the end
Anna mark story I'm dead
oh poor guy well looks like I'm layin a
survivor
they only the traitor the final station
yeah it's a better day we're going to
run across that Connor dunno
hello sir he is that I better take his
clothes oh okay okay I was gonna say get
naked for a second bloom please I'm
pretty pretty good do you fly the one
known that I did a jump well okay secret
agent now I got a lot like pretty cool
there's some one hand it's the hunter
but it's honor oh these are like rebels
just an egg I am at it as that I yeah
okay so you got drunk about the window
and I kind of luck out there Anna hey
guys
key back to Ray
I gotta find the trainer's oh yeah light
the lecture has already started
oh this is that like a church or save or
sing lesson I don't already get presents
but I can't find my [ __ ] a okay so I'm
basically going to still on those cars I
think and my way fool I'm putting a
great shape
pickle input if I marry some hours so
see the entrance exam word guerrilla
group but in it rational trying to hand
it out tonight changes
before go that path let me just check
this one real quick hello
so they down
I gotta say what they're going to do
okay I guess I wasn't counted
there's so much stuff here that you see
that going to top down here I love the
guns yes man this place is a gigantic
well there's one of those things oh my
god before tape test YPG nothing enough
it's crazy it's crazy doc what I doing
is kind of after they run closer
oh my god
I need to get outta hand for sure all
writing them my god it's the guy it's
the hunter dude he's so evil
okay I need a goner self what that I
need space
yeah Brower and spice now yeah we're
definitely in space just got a bag at
the end of it or something
this makes like now sounds like they're
like hey let's just scroll the storyline
hey down yeah he's like huh hey Senor
Senor Papa I'm on your anything you
learn can't pick up this I'm a quick
fighting anyone it's the whole story
thanks again Lex but so I'm like
invisible those eyes moles or photos I
can tell okay we're going to find the
hunters head Perry's got to be like some
alien or something what the heck what
years that's good nice anyway great
I just went back on the frickin 11 on
dreads
hello everyone I'm going to fill the
windows find a dump Cal they act my Jess
where does a solid fat that ok yeah
welcome there and that lame mom may all
time with for sure that ki Leona getting
at these nice clouds okay so say those
things
I'm sick fly into time
hey that's the generator thing hit
pictures like January I was fixing in
final station on the train I get my
control okay I'm going now can't punch
yet so I'm safe it doesn't seem like it
what the heck forget my start of this
game one week it starts getting crazy
what's happened here now let them for
the shelter yeah so what I can't go by
that what I had a sucky day tick comes
at ICAST my other special fairs
then brow that
okay I gotta polish
when I walk through the door what I'm in
the dark
and we got it's the guy from the last
Kenya final station
oh my god so that's how he got sick
yeah like poisoned by me okay that
closed a lot of thing and they went wow
great game great I got no I thank for
watching y'all that yeah